[MUSIC]
The time has come
This magic academy is a
good game star 2
Uh, don't talk about me Rice will face ruin here
me
ban
I won't let you do
that Come on, I'm your opponent for half a month
That's a good thing, it's the goodness and understanding of the
door, isn't it?
Ordos, the prince's child, tear It's like,
please say hello.
Talking is a class
.
Hey, I
can't take it alone, it's a pain, and it's a
2-point specification
.
It
seems like you're fine with your feet already Catalina-sama
[music]
What is this
?
Why did you bark for some reason? Do you know
where this place is
?  I've finished pasting it I've been
running down the Ota-ku road since I was in middle school and entered high school and became a pillar in otome games After playing games all night
I'm almost late for school
[Music] It's a
medical condition bar
How are you feeling?
I put it on
and he has a scratch on it, so please
don't worry about it
.  Music]
social circles, 2 Zaku sand, mentors, and things like on-
manager Compared to that, it was tu in my previous life.
I'm going to say hello again.
[Music]
It's a celebration tonight.
It's because she's an otaku girl, so
even though she's a youth in society, she's a fiancée according to her.
The villain of the song, Reizo, repairs the scar on his forehead and binds him to the prince's
favor Bap
Jo's Three
Greats  It's still too early to
make a decision Oh, I don't remember
Surucha Midsummer Festival An otome game that nurtures love with a character set in a magic school in a certain country
Maria of the Jingu Shrine is a trading inn with the magical power of light Age
15  Maria entered the Magic Academy as a target for flight 4
[Music] The
first one is the strong start
of the third Otsu.
Twin brother Alan
Tiart I wasn't looking for you,
I guess I just happened to be passing by
[Music] The
third is Katarina's brother-in-law.
I
want you to like me, I've thrown away your thoughts And
um Catalina kreis
Geold's fiancée and villainess
She eats by whatever route she leaves the house Yes
If it's a happy ending, I've been harassing the protagonist like a crime Catalina is deprived of her sister  If it's
a
bad ending, the main character will attack with a knife, and Catalina will be attacked by Mr. Onko.
I'm sure I'll
write about the same route on my journey outside Panipani
line I've never had a chance
The world of the world, I
'm just like this
[music] I
slowly mixed it up, but I admired it
ah ah ah
me
Amazing
ah ah ah
[music]
me
goo
[music]
me
[music
] huh  Without splitting it up, I put up this video and said, "Let's be beautiful," Moon cuts off his magic
[music]
me
Pabu From
now on, we'll start sailing around the sea for the first ruined end hall day
I hope you have a good idea
Please go ahead, Katarina's skirt Deer got engaged, but that's fine, but I
've already been doing it from the old world, so I wonder
if I can do
that.  It's the duty of those who have it.
Please take a look. When Katarina was 5 years old, her father Marc was
active.
It's okay if I can't maintain the main character of that game, so even if I
don't bully Pique, I can still be made a
gatherer, so the Earth Old puts on the mask of an angel and quickly becomes Rose.
If it's for the sake of it, there's the possibility of
humiliating Katarina.
If you can use the ribbon, you
shouldn't have trouble finding a job
even if you're deported.
I'm sorry, but the doctor said that there was nothing
wrong with me.In order to deepen my magical power, I decided to deal with the source of my magical power
.
Speaking of dealing with and interacting with soil, it's an
up resolution, so what's Hadatsuki Guru is the pattern of talking with Jiji
?  But
it's more important than that, lady g Old-sama has
come to see me.
I think he's having a conversation with his father for training, so I thought the best way to do that would be to cultivate a field
.
I thought I was going to be deported,
Katarina.
It's the
same as the game I got engaged to, but I don't want to quit my
life halfway through.
Keith Kuratsu is
the child of a distant relative with a lonely background
. Because he was the child of a mistress, he grew up being bullied by his brothers.
The
cases that grew up as if to bury that loneliness became various women and those
who had an affair But when I met Sujin 4 in the game, my loneliness was healed and I fell in true love.
Catalina was exiled from the country and was killed by using magic powers
.
Asagao
goo
I have no choice but to do it for myself download
Me I
couldn't
ana
Please wait I don't want Keith to be lonely If I don't get lonely I won't fall in love with the main character of the game
Katalina won't come to ruin
[music]
Pane The
weather is nice and I'm going to show Mira around
Thank you Catalina for me  We've become powerful, so
you
can call me sister, but if it's rude, it's my dream to be called sister
.  I'm making it
next time I'll let you eat the freshly caught, it's delicious
[music]
There were fish in the past, so you can fish,
fishing together 8
[Music]
My favorite place was Gifu
Gakuya The
view from the top of
the tree is amazing.
Then I'll teach you, look at my body
[music]
teacher praised me for being a tree climbing genius
please
,
there was
[music]
pandan
I was surprised when I heard that I fell from a tree  It's great that
you're safe.I usually climb well, but I got carried away and fell
down.Is that so?
We've become closer than before, yeah,
yeah, there's a lot of things going on, and my mother
misunderstood me as the child of my father's lover, and I'm in danger of getting divorced
.
Thanks to that, my sword training has progressed. Thank you Peace.
I can't
show you.
Ah,
if you buy 2 clay dolls, the labor cost is zero.
Do
n't you think? wh I'm glad you didn't eat I was worried about the
boiling car
How are
you feeling
?
He has strong magic, but he still can't use it properly.
That's why I promised him I wouldn't use it unnecessarily
.
I understood very well the horror of my magic,
so I was very surprised when I heard that I used
it.
Keith warned me about it, but I didn't listen to what I was told, and the doll in approached me
.
You've woken up, haven't you? Cheese That's locked up in her room with a duplicate key
nice
[music]
there's a bird then ok
eh look yeah
this
[music]
[laughter]
ah ah  I can go
tee
ah ah ah
If you think I'm near the door, go away
What's wrong with my sister's apology?
I'm going to hurt
you, so it's not okay You should train from now on so that you can control your power
Let's do our best together with me
No excuses welcome
[music]